crime violence and fear have run rampant
our great city is being destroyed
people want justice restored to this
world people want heroes Mazzoni
but heroes are not born they're created
that's what your father and I were
trying to do
create heroes
whoa whoa whoa chills just a mask see
don't freak out right
hey youtubers is Charlie and as you can
see they just posted the new trailer for
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles this is the
dark gritty reboot Michael Bay version
of Ninja Turtles and not the campy
animated cartoon that we all remember
and love from the 90s or the cartoon
that's going on right now while I am
excited to have new live-action Ninja
Turtles especially a big new franchise
that could potentially run for many many
years there are a few things that we
have to talk about mostly the notable
changes that they've made to the story
that's right they've been collapsing a
few of the story elements on each other
most notably the origin story of the
Ninja Turtles it seems like nowadays
everyone's stuck on the idea of a Super
Soldier Serum you know genetic tampering
so you have Marvel with the Super
Soldier Serum in Captain America and in
Winter Soldier and then you have it in
arrow with the mirakuru so both Marvel
and DC are doing it so why shouldn't
enjoy Turtles do it too that's right if
you didn't get it from the trailer the
new origin story is is that the shredder
played by William Fichtner who obviously
is just staring at the mast now will
become shredder through the course of
the movie and April O'Neill's father are
now responsible for the creation of the
new Turtles
you know attempting to try and create
some sort of super soldier it's a little
bit like the original but in the
original it was mostly you know man's
crimes against nature that created the
Ninja Turtles not man's crimes against
man there's also the issue of changing
the race of the shredder and changing
some of those elements the only big
reason that I can think of to do that is
so that the movie will play better to an
international audience and they just
don't want to make someone who's either
Japanese or Chinese the villain of the
movie so the movie will play well in
China because that's you know like an
extra billion people for a movie to play
to overall I think it's gonna be an
interesting movie I don't know a whole
lot about the director he's actually the
same person who directed battle Los
Angeles which you know doesn't inspire a
lot of confidence but with Michael Bay
kind of behind the scenes it's going to
be entertaining so I will enjoy it in
the theater the only downside being that
it's not going to be a deep allegory to
any of the original stories it's just
going to be a fun reboot you know Allah
JJ Abrams Star Trek this first teaser
trailer was really just kind of intended
to highlight the change in the origin
story and kind of set up who the
villains who the heroes are and give you
a good you know full frontal look at the
Ninja Turtle
I also think it's really interesting
that Michael Bay ended up working with
Megan Fox again after their whole
transformer snafu after the second movie
but let me know what do you think about
the trailer are you excited to see a new
live-action movie you know are you
concerned about all the changes they
made to the origin story do you not care
hopefully we'll get a new trailer in a
couple months and we'll get an idea for
the story's going to be but sound off in
the comments love it or hate it or we
can just reminisce about the old classic
series I'm interested to see how this
movie plays against some of the other
big action movies this year you can
actually click here to watch my Winter
Soldier trailer breakdown and you can
click here to watch my breakdown of
guardians of the galaxy it'll be really
interesting to see how they all stack up
at the end of the year but thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives